today women around the globe have less
access to power wealth and education
than men but one tiny island is leading
the world in bridging these gaps Iceland
is pioneering ways to get more mothers
back to work to root out gender
stereotypes and to close the pay gap
it's a human rights issue isn't it
paying the same wage for equally
valuable jobs could Iceland inspire the
world to solve one of its greatest
problems equality is absolutely the key
to everything
Iceland has topped gender equality
rankings for nearly a decade one of the
secrets to their success start early
this kindergarten in the capital wreck
of egg focuses on challenging extreme
gender stereotypes before they take root
in boys and girls for boys for example
always be strong always decisive always
taking charge they will enter bullying
fighting breaking rules will do it with
a curse as well if you're always helpful
caring
things about others always looking as a
friend for acceptance you will have
forgotten about yourself we need to get
away from the extreme qualities we need
to get more in the middle all of us it's
a mission that's led to the creation of
17 schools across this tiny country all
focused on developing a healthy balance
of characteristics in both sexes girls
and boys are separated to allow girls to
nurture traits traditionally viewed as
masculine like being bold
independent and taking risks um boys are
given time to learn traits traditionally
viewed as feminine like being more group
oriented empathetic and caring and the
signs are that this is working research
suggests that in later years children
from this school have a greater
understanding of gender equality when
compared to children from other schools
there is nothing like our quick fix to
this shoots yes then at last we will
catch Amish rest Iceland is also
promoting gender equality by encouraging
fathers to share the childcare burden
with mothers in 2000 it introduced what
is known as a daddy quota 3-month
statutory paternity leave
it's an allowance that goes much further
than most other countries in the world
here over 70% of fathers take up the
full three months leave why because the
state covers 80% of a salary during this
period up to a cap of $4,600 a month one
beneficiary of this generous system is
Eagle be honest in' who is looking after
his son Varla echo believes the high
cost of the daddy quota to taxpayers is
justified because it helps get more
women into work imagine having some
applicants from a man and a woman you
need much less likely to take into the
equation that the woman who could have a
child in the future and go on a leave
because the man is also going to do that
so it does create a more equal field out
there but even in Iceland men are still
paid nearly 6% more than women for
similar work this year Iceland became
the first country in the world to pass
legislation not just to expose but to
tackle the gender pay gap companies with
over 25 employees like Reykjavik Energy
now have to prove they are paying men
and women equally for similar jobs
every job at the company must be
measured against a set of criteria this
produces a score for jobs with the same
score workers must be paid the same when
reykjavik energy used this pay
calculator the inequalities came into
sharp and immediate focus we noticed
that there was a pay gap there between
the unskilled workers that were outside
and the unskilled workers inside the
outside unskilled workers are mainly men
and the unskilled workers inside that's
the cleaning staff was that in the
kitchen that's the mostly women what's
important to keep in mind is the gender
pay gap it's not there because there's a
couple of evil men making decisions to
pay women less it's this unconscious
bias that we all have we place more
value on traditionally male-dominated
jobs the company rectified this by
raising the wages of its female
employees critics of the law point out
there will be significant financial
consequences for companies as they
rectify their pay inequalities but many
argue this is a necessary price to pay
it's a human rights issue isn't it
paying the same wage for equally
valuable jobs having a law that requires
company to have this it makes everyone a
comfortable gender equality will be an
ever more pressing challenge for wealthy
countries across the world could the
ambitious measures being tested in
Iceland provide practical solutions
you